how's it going bros my name is fear pack
today I have some very exciting news I'm
so proud to finally announce something
that we've been working on for a very
long time rebel mom rebel mom is me and
a bunch of really awesome youtubers
coming together as a group to do awesome
things but rebel mode is a network and
if you're a youtuber yourself you might
have a better understanding of what that
really means but basically as a youtuber
you may be more or less dependent on a
network to make your living on YouTube I
have been with a network throughout my
entire history on YouTube and it's
something that I haven't really talked
about that much but it's it's been a
roller coaster
although networks is a topic that I feel
very strongly about and it's something
that I almost feel a bit of
responsibility in for some time the
biggest channel
I think networks can be something very
positive for everyone involved there
should be something that helps channels
on YouTube grow and reach their maximum
potential and help them in whatever way
they can really I think this is possible
and I think this is possible with rebel
mode and that's why I wanted to create
this network from the start we're just
going to be this group of selected
people we want to keep it smaller to
really make it work but I hope in the
future that you can be involved as well
we're backed by another huge network
called maker
which means we got all the resources to
make this as awesome as possible
we do lose a little bit of hipster cred
though but again if you're just a fan
then you get to enjoy me and a bunch of
other really awesome youtubers and I'd
really like making videos together if
you want to check out more information
on how you can get involved check out
the link in the description there will
be beautiful beautiful websites
cool cool slates and all that also
I did a shout out competition so long
ago I apologize but I thought it we
could be really cool to maybe keep some
of the smaller channels part of the
network
so stay tuned for that announcement it
will come and yeah that was all I wanted
to say thank you for listening really
appreciate it I'm very proud to be here
today talking about this topic it's
something that I really really wanted to
do for a long time and I really do
appreciate you both supporting this I
hope you're on board that's it for me
for now thank you for watching and as
always stay awesome press click the logo
our description for more info click it
now before the video